let's speak next to
isaac
from
wyoming isaac from wyoming please
hello david thanks for taking my call i
appreciate you uh taking a chance on
somebody from wyoming i love wyoming
thank you
have you been to wyoming never
but i would like to go i hear that you
know there's like a big sky there and
stuff
yeah big sky and bad politics okay
um so i guess my question is it's kind
of silly because i sort of already know
the answer and honestly i just jumped in
here and
admittedly not completely prepared but
uh
my question is
do you have any plans in the future to
sort of hire your own investigative
journalists which i've seen you've been
doing
somewhat uh recently and sort of just
expand into a legitimate news outlet
well we are completely illegitimate
currently and so your concern is
certainly warranted will we ever have an
air of legitimacy that's fair many
people ask me that uh that that's the
fair question uh no i know what you're
saying i mean we we we're a commentary
and analysis show we're not a news
reporting show and we don't we don't
pretend uh otherwise yeah maybe i'm i'm
always open to considering anything i
just think we have to think about like
as a small organization if we hire one
investigative reporter
can we really do
something that we feel is meaningful and
we can feel good about compared to
entities with just overwhelmingly more
resources but i have no opposition to it
in principle
awesome uh
other than that uh
one more question as someone uh who's
more left-leaning in our red state what
types of things would you recommend uh
for people in my situation to sort of
influence
politics in the state and push it
towards the left more in many red states
where there's like a tradition of voting
for republicans but people are actually
open to different ideas getting involved
in ballot initiatives can be really
effective because rather than saying hey
vote for this democrat which maybe isn't
going to happen you can find ballot
initiatives that are
reasonable moves to the left
um that will not seem as scary to a
republican electorate and so i would
look at getting involved in ballot
initiatives whether they be about
campaign finance the environment
whatever's important to you
awesome yeah actually in wyoming there
there is an ongoing effort to create a
ballot initiative to legalize marijuana
that has thus failed so far because the
signature requirements are so
big you know we just can't get the
signature requirements yes
in any case thanks for talking to me and
uh i love the show all right thank you
so much let us know if uh you make any
headway there in uh in wyoming
even if like me you're not vegan and
you're not vegetarian um eating a more
plant-based diet is a really great thing
to do for a number of different reasons
and our sponsor just egg is the
delicious plant-based egg you can use it
anywhere you use traditional eggs
because the taste and texture are
identical but just egg plant-based eggs
have the same amount of protein as
traditional eggs i use it all the time
at home you can make fluffy scrambled
eggs you can make omelets you can make
quiche frittata crepes
fried rice you should see my fried rice
recipe you can really use it anywhere in
baking or anywhere you would use
traditional eggs when i first tried just
egg
i was surprised that a plant-based egg
could both taste and cook
just like traditional eggs you can get
it at the grocery store instacart amazon
go try it eating a more plant-based diet
is a great decision i do it and i'm not
vegan or vegetarian and just egg makes
it that much more easy and delicious